[Applaus]
[Musik]
könnt ihr euch noch an diese bilder
erinnern sie stammen aus dem september
2021 als afghanistan wieder an die
taliban viel sie sind also weniger als
ein jahr alt seitdem scheint dennoch
eine ewigkeit vergangen zu sein zu jener
zeit sah es danach aus als würden die
usa ihre bis dahin faktisch gelten die
globale vorherrschaft verlieren das ende
des amerikanischen imperiums schiene
kommen eine multipolare welt in der anti
senna und lag sogar mit russland um die
globale geopolitische dominanz
konkurrieren müsste aber überraschung
beschreiben nun sommer 2022 und die lage
stellt sich letztendlich völlig anders
da als damals von viel vorhergesagt ganz
genau im heutigen video werden sie euch
zeigen dass das amerikanische imperium
aktuellen mächtiger ist als je zuvor
[Musik]
ich werde sogar noch etwas darüber
hinaus geht hier zum beispiel schon mal
etwas vom projekt vor der new american
century für das neue amerikanische
jahrhundert gehört ich greife an dieser
stelle schon mal etwas vor wenn das neue
amerikanische jahrhundert ist zurück und
es ist gekommen um zu bleiben was ich
damit meine nun wer von euch kann sich
noch einen ersten top ganzen erinnern
falls ihr noch wie ich irgendwas von den
80er jahren mitbekommen habt dann werdet
ihr diese sind ganz sicher gesehen haben
er ist mittlerweile ein kult sender
überraschender weise tatsächlich helfen
kann die letzten jahre des kalten
krieges zu verstehen er spielt in einer
zeit in der die vereinigten staaten der
sowjetunion militärisch deutlich
überlegen waren die amerikanischen
piloten den top ganz im gerd alfers im
grunde nur durch sich selbst besiegt
werden könnten und es ist nicht
bemerkenswert dass ausgerechnet in
diesem jahr die fortsetzung von top
damit über alpha tom cruise in die kinos
kommt ja matte liegen visual politik
zuschauer das alles scheint kein zufall
zu sein denn es deutet alles darauf hin
dass die ubisoft erneut die rolle des
weltpolizisten übernommen haben und es
auf lange sicht niemanden geben wörter
ihnen diesbezüglich ernsthaft die stirn
bieten könnte um es noch einmal klar zu
sagen wir meinen damit eine weltweite
militärische dominanz und zwar noch auf
jahrzehnte hin die ereignisse der
letzten monate werfen ihr lichts oder
ihre schatten auf eine neue realität die
es zu verstehen gilt daher stellen wir
uns heute die folgenden fragen von
welcher bedeutung sind die vereinigten
staaten als weltpolizei heute stehen wir
wirklich vor dem ende der einst
ausgerufenen multipolaren welt heute
werden wir euch die antworten auf diese
fragen liefern und wie so oft beginnen
wir hier zuerst einmal mit einem kurzen
blick wichtige geschichte
[Musik]
von der pax americana für wild polizei
kennt ihr den begriff new york oder auch
neokonservative vielleicht werden
jüngere leute nicht wissen wovon ich
rede solltet ihr aber über 30 sein und
euch die wir für politik interessiert
dann habt ihr diese bezeichnung sicher
schon eine million mal gehört der
neokonservatismus war in den ersten
jahren des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts eine angesagte ideologie
des rechten politischen flügels in den
usa als geburtsstunde der modernen kunst
kann das ja 1997 angesehen werden als
das project for a new american century
ins leben gerufen wurde es handelt sich
dabei um einen sogenannten fängt eine
denkfabrik welche von diesen beiden
herren maßgeblich beeinflusst wurde wenn
christel und robert käding und wofür
stehen diese beiden gentlemen nun um es
auf den punkt zu bringen die usa sollten
die einzige dominante macht und die
uneingeschränkte weltpolizei sein und
bleiben nichts geringeres als das die
welt sei schließlich ein gefährlicher
ort und ständig bestimmt die gefahr
eines krieges der umstand dass die
meisten von uns noch nie auf einem
schlachtfeld kämpfen mussten sei eine
historische anomalie eine anomalie die
entsprechend der neokonservativen
sichtweise einen namen hat pax americana
zur pax americana haben der übrigen
schon ein eigenes video gedreht das ich
bei euch verlinken werde aber wie kam es
überhaupt soweit nun versetzt euch
einmal in folgendes hinein als die
sowjetunion in den 90er jahren außer
gefecht gesetzt war stürzte dies die
vereinigten staaten in eine
identitätskrise
wer war nun ihr feind gegen wen galt es
damals doch zu kämpfen und sich zu
rüsten wozu brauchen sie eigentlich noch
ein so gewaltiges militär und so viele
geheimdienste betrachtet doch dazu bitte
einmal folgende grafik
wenn ihr euch diese grafik anschaut
werdet ihr schnell feststellen dass die
vereinigten staaten ihren
militärhaushalt drastisch gekürzt haben
nachdem sich die sowjetunion aufgelöst
hatte man könnte sagen dass dies ein
ausdruck einer gewissen ziellosigkeit
war vergleichbar mit einem
hochleistungssportler der wie verrückt
für ein wettbewerb trainiert hatte der
dann jedoch nie stattfand und wie ein
leistungssportler ohne aufgabe und
motivation ließ die usa mitsamt ihren
westlichen partner nun ihre muskeln ein
wenig kümmern gleichzeitig begaben sie
sich auf sinnsuche auf die suche nach
aufgaben einer perspektive und einer
neuen doktrin das war doch nicht einfach
das weltbild viele politiker und
strategen hatte sich mit dem zerfall des
ostblocks grundlegend geändert man
könnte sagen dass der autor dieses buch
ist der ideologe der neunziger jahre war
der mann den er jetzt auf dem bildschirm
sieht heißt francis fukuyama er schrieb
das buch das ende der geschichte und der
letzte mensch fukuyama stellt darin die
these auf dass der verlauf der
geschichte keine anhäufung von zufällen
sei sondern dass sie einer
gesetzmäßigkeit folge würde die sie
letztendlich im sieg der liberalen
demokratie mythen lassen müsse er führt
weiter aus dass dieser finale zeitpunkt
mit dem zusammenbruch des open air und
die liberale demokratie damit faktisch
besiegt habe und nun an wäre es nur noch
eine frage der zeit bis alle länder der
welt zu gelebten demokratie würden und
friedlich miteinander handel treiben wer
wolle schließlich in einer diktatur
leben wenn doch klar wäre dass die
demokratie in jeder hinsicht besser sei
nun leider lässt fukuyama theorie eine
ganz entscheidende grundvoraussetzung
außer acht dass die menschheit nämlich
ganz naturgemäß zu einem ganz bestimmten
anteil ausmacht geilen psychopathen
besteht mitsamt ihrer zugehörigen fans
opportunisten und mitläufer durch der
hilfe sie eine demokratisch gerechte
verteilung der macht unterbieten können
und selbst mehr davon zu erlangen die
demokratie wird daher immer unter
angriff stehen und sie wird sich nicht
von selbst verteidigen ihre kunst sind
deswegen der ansicht dass die demokratie
auf keinen fall etwas natürliches sei
ihrer ansicht nach wäre eine welt ohne
eine effektive polizei die für die
aufrechterhaltung der internationalen
ordnung eintritt zur diktatur verdammt
man kann nun meinen dieser gedanke sei
zynisch aber leider fehlt ist in der
geschichte nicht an entsprechenden
beispiel mit den aufnahmen der kriege im
ehemaligen jugoslawien den völkermord in
ruanda und den anschlägen am 11
september 2001 galt die these fukuyama
es für viele als widerlegt und samuel
huntingtons kampf der kulturen wurde
sehr populär und schaut euch nun bitte
einmal folgende karte an
auf dieser darstellung könnt ihr die us
militärbasen auf der ganzen welt sehen
abgesehen von einigen wenigen gebieten
kann man sagen das ist ungefähr alle
1000 kilometer eine us
militäreinrichtungen gibt kein anderes
land der erde verfügt über so etwas gut
gibt es auch andere länder mit
militärbasen außerhalb ihrer grenzen ja
natürlich gibt es die aber weder
russland noch china kommen an die zahl
der us-amerikanischen basel heran weil
es beispielsweise der iran im jahr 2021
bild an der straße und hormus
attackierte waren die vereinigten
staaten innerhalb von wenigen stunden
dazu in der lage schiffe soldaten und
flugzeuge in das gebiet entsenden und
die region wieder sagen wir mal zu
befrieden gut auf jeden fall für ordnung
zu sorgen solche aktionen können die usa
nahezu auf den ganzen planeten
durchführen im laufe der zwanzigsten
jahrhundert sah sich an bisher noch
ununterbrochen im wettbewerb mit anderen
supermächten insbesondere mit der
sowjetunion mit beginn des 21
jahrhunderts änderte sich die lage und
es gab plötzlich niemanden mehr der
washington das wasser reichen konnte
damals waren dies einige als gute
gelegenheit lich verteidigungsausgaben
drastisch zu kürzen die neo konzern das
aber ganz anders
gegenwärtig haben die vereinigten
staaten keinen globalen rivalen amerikas
große strategie sollte darauf abzielen
diese vorteilhafte position zu erhalten
und so weit wie möglich in die zukunft
auszubauen dies ist ein auszug aus einem
bericht der im jahr 2000 vom project for
the new american century veröffentlicht
wurde in diesem bericht wird offen
gefordert dass das amerikanische militär
nicht nur der landesverteidigung dienen
sondern auch als weltpolizei agieren
solle diese rolle soll mit hilfe der
weltweiten militärbasen und dadurch sie
herum die fähigkeit schnell in jedem
konflikt eingreifen zu können erfüllt
werden in diesem bericht wurde nebenbei
bemerkt auch vorgeschlagen die
entwicklung der f-35 des teuersten
rüstungsprojekt aller zeiten abzubrechen
das dokument sollte als ideologischer
leitfaden zu der republikanischen partei
dienen allerdings hörte damals niemand
auf dieses denken könnt ihr euch noch an
den ehemaligen us präsidenten namens
george
bush erinnern achtet mal darauf dass
dieser während seines wahlkampfes in
jener zeit über den neo kurz gesagt wenn
wir nicht aufhören unsere truppen
überall auf der welt in missionen zum
aufbau von nationen zu schicken werden
wir bald ein ernstes problem haben und
das werde ich verhindern dort stabil
bush während des wahlkampfs im jahr 2000
doch dann kam der älteste september 2001
und plötzlich endet bush seinen ton
vollkommen die ganze welt hörte nun den
neo kurz zu wo schwer vor kurzem noch
gesagt hatte er wolle eben nicht mehr
der weltpolizist seien dann gleich zwei
kriege zwei kriege mit dem
vordergründigen ziel diktatur zu stürzen
und sie durch demokratien zu ersetzen
polizeiarbeit eben und natürlich mussten
die vereinigten staaten in der folge
ihre militärausgaben erhöhen und wie
sehr zeigt diese grafik
[Musik]
nur leider beruhte einer dieser kriege
da gegen den irak von vornherein auf
einen gigantischen betrug die
us-regierung um moscheen und rumsfeld
hatte beweise gefälscht uns hat er
musste ihn zu stürzen und einen anteil
am großen rüstungs kuchen in eigene und
die taschen von freunden zu spülen ja so
war das damals nicht gerade die beste
arzt der polizeiarbeit und sogar im
ersten jahrzehnt der 2000er jahre der
lange sogenannte krieg gegen den terror
nun waren nicht mehr die russischen
kommunisten die bösewichte sondern al
qaida die taliban um deren echte und
angebliche unterstützer aus der sicht
der amerikanischen gesellschaft
unterschieden sich die alten und die
neuen gegner allerdings grundlegend der
bedrohung durch die sowjets waren sich
die amerikaner durchaus unmittelbar
bewusst schließlich hatten die russen
atombomben von den islamischen
terroristen gegen eine andere bedrohung
aus einer die zwar eher zu nehmen war
die aber als nicht ganz so elementar
wahrgenommen wurde und nun kommen wir
zurück zur top gun denn möchte man den
damaligen zeitgeist verstehen kann eine
analyse der hollywoodfilm aus der
jeweiligen dekaden nützlich sein nehmen
wir mal den zweiten weltkrieg die
traumfabrik in nl produzierte zu dieser
zeit unzählige kriegsfilm ihr in denen
der helden der us armee im kampf gegen
die nazis gefeiert worden wollte man
sich alle meisterwerke dieser kategorie
ansehen wäre man wohl zum streamen
verdammt bis in alle ewigkeit für alle
die das nicht gemerkt haben dass war
gerade ein lama job zu einem klassiker
aber zurück zu unserer geschichte in den
80er jahren kamen dann die filme zum
kalten krieg in die kinos hier waren der
regel ist vws die bösen denen die
amerikanerin mutig entgegentreten und
natürlich siegten es gibt unzählige
beispiele top gun die vier rambo zwei
und drei und so weiter und so fort aber
welche filme hat uns hollywood zu den
kriegen im irak und in afghanistan
präsentiert nun hier gibt es eklatante
unterschiede die meisten von ihnen haben
vielschichtig interpretierbare und nicht
selten satirisch angehauchten
geschichten wie zb hattrick kings oder
team america das alles in filme in denen
sich desorientierte soldaten außer
stande sehen die an sie gestellten
erwartungen zu erfüllen und ordnung
demokratien die von ihnen befreiten
länder zu bringen dazu müsst ihr
verstehen dass der amerikanischen
gesellschaft und damit auch den
einfachen soldaten damals vor den
einsätzen glauben gemacht wurde dass die
kriege im irak und in afghanistan kurze
interventionen seien würden
dementsprechend bei die allgemeine grund
zunächst gewissermaßen positiven
doch die jeder mit augen im kopf stellen
sehen konnte würden sich die usa
jahrzehntelang engagieren müssen um in
diesen ländern demokratischen
regierungen immobilien und festigen zu
können heute wissen wir wohin das alles
geführt hat ja wie blöd kann man nur
sein wenn er sich ja viele von euch
denken einige von euch werden sich ja
davon überzeugt sein dass man demokratie
nicht mit waffengewalt herstellen kann
nur nach allem was wir von den waffen
gängen in afghanistan irak mitbekommen
haben ist dies auch eine verständliche
haltung vergesst aber bitte nicht die
geschichtlichen beispiele deutschland
und japan beide sicher eher positive
beispiele für funktionierenden
demokratien haben ihr aktuelles
politisches system auch nicht auf
friedliche weise bekommen verbunden mit
dem selbstvertrauen das die amerikaner
nicht zuletzt wegen filmen wie top gun
hatten konnte man damals durchaus
glauben dass die usa schnell mit dem
problem in diesen ländern sind fertig
werden würden des weiteren glauben viel
das ist vor allem die falken der rechte
flügel der republikaner war die solche
kriege befürworteten und die
amerikanische linke also die demokraten
er der friedensbewegung zuzurechnen
seien nun pustekuchen denn wenn es
jemanden gibt den wir für das vorläufige
ende des neuen amerikanischen
jahrhunderts verantwortlich machen
müssen dann wäre es niemand geringeres
als dieser
von diesem tag an wird eine neue vision
unser land regieren von diesem tag an
wird ist nur noch america first heißen
amerika zuerst
america first das klingt wie einer
dieser vermeintlich kritischen
wahlkampfslogans diese typischerweise
aus den usa kennen slogans die ein
positives image des jeweiligen
kandidaten transportieren sollen und
wenn man das mal nüchtern betrachtet ist
ist für den präsidenten eines landes ja
auch logisch die interessen seiner
wähler an erster stelle auf seiner
prioritätenliste zu sehen egal ob man
den rechten und den linken politischen
flügel angehört oder könnt ihr euch
vorstellen dass ein us-präsident egal ob
demokrat oder republikaner von sich
sagen würde ich stelle die interessen
unseres landes hinten an
[Musik]
allerdings führt eine solche
eindimensionale betrachtung dieses
slogans in die er hinter america first
verbarg sich ein viel weitreichender
ideologische ansatz den tram vertrat die
these dass sich sein land in den letzten
jahrzehnten unnötig in eine nachteilige
position gedreht hatte dies betraf
seiner meinung nach sowohl die
internationale wirtschaftspolitik als
auch die militärische ausrichtung
amerikas trump war es schlicht leid
amerikas militär dafür einzusetzen die
probleme anderer länder zu lösen und er
war bereits sehr weit zu gehen um dem
ein ende zu setzen trump diskutierte den
austritt der usa aus der nato sagen
berater in mit neue sorgen über russland
ihr habt richtig gehört trump bei der
erste amtsinhaber im weißen haus der
offen und ernsthaft das ende der nato in
erwägung im zuge dessen hielten auch
einige seinen europäischen amtskollegen
ein solches ende vermutlich so durch
macht folgendes an
marc gross sagt die nato allianz liege
im hirntod ehemaligen zuschauer es ist
nur wenige monate her da stand die
existenz der nato tatsächlich zur
debatte in den kreisen der
internationalen politik war zu jener
zeit von einer neuen multipolaren welt
die rede es wurde eine welt gezeichnet
in der die vorherrschaft der usa von
anderen mächten angefochten würde erster
stelle dachte man hier natürlich an
china und dann vielleicht auch im
ausland fans unseres kanals erinnert
sich auch noch an all die videos die wir
schon vor zwei jahren über die deutsche
energiepolitik gemacht haben diese
zeigen dass es zeiten gab in denen auch
deutschland komplett entgegen den
interessen der usa sowie den
sicherheitsinteressen seinen
europäischen nachbarn handelte und jetzt
versetzt euch mal in einen
größenwahnsinnigen imperialisten mit
minderwertigkeitskomplex übler die mir
putin hinein welches bild dürfte
angesichts dieser entwicklungen all
dieses wasser auf die mühlen seiner
allmacht träume in seinem kopf
entstanden sein ja genau das bild
welches der demokratischen westen damals
abgab musste geradezu wie eine einladung
wirken sich all das mit gewalt zu nehmen
was er haben wollte aber es geht nicht
um kopien wenn gleichzeitig offenbarte
sich dazu noch an anderen fronten das
forschen an einfluss und macht verloren
dazu müsst ihr euch nur folgende bilder
aus dem september 2021 ansehen
man kann es drehen und wenden wie man
will die rückeroberung afghanistans
durch die taliban war ein bombastischer
fällt für die usa ein sinnbild zu den
niedergang des amerikanischen imperiums
und china erkannte sofort die
gelegenheit das ding an sich in
afghanistan 30 machen da mein eigenes
video dazu beträgt doch dann kam das
jahr 2022 und alles änderte sich in
welche richtung genau das sehen wir uns
jetzt an
[Musik]
das neue amerikanische jahrhundert
schon vor putins überfall auf die
ukraine haben wir hier auch israel
politik darauf hingewiesen dass ein
solcher krieg eine falle für den kreml
darstellen würde die meisten anderen
analysten haben damals jedoch weder mit
einem derart starken widerstandswillen
der ukraine noch mit dem überraschenden
militärischen fähigkeiten dieses landes
gerechnet dennoch kann man nicht sagen
dass die ukraine aus diesen krieg als
sieger in einem nachhaltigen sinn
hervorgehen kann es ist offensichtlich
dass sie für immer gezeichnet sein wird
die wirtschaft des landes ist
zusammengebrochen viele städte und
ortschaften sind zerstört der staat hat
die kontrolle über weite teile seines
gebietes verloren es herrscht eine
humanitäre katastrophe und alle zeichen
deuten darauf hin dass dieser krieg noch
lange nicht vorbei ist die narben werden
tief und die traumata auch über
generationen hinweg nicht zu verarbeiten
sein auf der anderen seite jedoch wird
russland mit jeder sekunde die vergeht
schwächer und schwächer die nato dagegen
wird immer stärker noch bis vor ein paar
monaten war ein möglicher nato-beitritt
finnlands und schwedens schlicht
undenkbar und nun befinden sich beide
länder im turbo beitrittsprozess sogar
die türkei unterstützen ihre
mitgliedschaft das verteidigungsbündnis
expandiert dabei nicht nur quantitativ
sondern vor allem auch qualitativ man
wächst noch stärker zusammen die
gemeinsame strukturen werden immer
engmaschiger die vollkommene nato
visierung europas ist nun nicht mehr
aufzuhalten wir dürfen nicht vergessen
dass noch vor kurzem die immer wieder
von den usa geforderte erhöhung der
verteidigungsetat für viele europäische
regierungen eher wie eine abwegige idee
erschien heute kann allein die
bundeswehr zusätzlich zu den normalen
haushaltsmitteln über ein sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden euro verfügen auch
wenn ein großteil dieser summe gerade
mal dafür reichen wird die allergrößten
defizite zu kompensieren andere länder
sprechen davon ihre ausgaben für
verteidigung sogar verdoppeln vor kurzem
haben wir über das große vorbild polen
in einem eigenen video berichtet um
jedoch die wahre bedeutung all dessen zu
begreifen müssen wir das ganze noch mal
aus einer anderen perspektive beleuchten
die nato ist ein militärbündnis zwar
sind die usa nur eines der mitglieder
allerdings stellen sie aufgrund ihrer
militärischen und wirtschaftlichen
stärke das bei weitem einflussreichste
da schon bei der entstehung der nato
waren die usa die treibende kraft man
wollte gemeinsam einen wehrhaften blog
liberaler demokratien schaffen im
bündnis gegen die damals übermächtig
erscheint es doch mit union doch dann
nahm die geschichte ihren lauf und seit
dem ende des warschauer pakts und der
sowjetunion wurde der nordatlantische
verteidigungsbündnis
zeit einfach andere prioritäten
doch mit den aktuellen ereignissen haben
sich diese dinge schlagartig geändert
wir sind wieder alle zusammen auf dem
weg in einen neuen kalten und vielleicht
auch heißen krieg wieder bilden europa
und die usa eine gemeinsame block gegen
russland allerdings gibt es dieses mal
einen gewaltigen und entscheidenden
unterschied zu den zeiten des ersten
kalten krieges war der gegner nicht
russland sondern die sowjetunion ein
vielvölkerstaat mit bis zu 120
nationalitäten und 15 teilrepubliken der
weit über die grenzen russlands
hinausreichte wenn auch eher von den
russen dominiert wurde rossi fi zierung
das heißt die ansiedlung ethnische
russen in allen sv veert republiken bei
gleichzeitiger vertreibung verschleppung
oder darf er nicht unter einheimischen
bevölkerung gehört zum standard
repertoire des kreml egal ob dort fahren
oder kommunistische generalsekretäre
saßen ethnische säuberung und völkermord
erschien den meisten herrschern in
moskau wie auch vielen russen selbst als
ganz natürlicher bestandteil ihrer
politischen kultur tja und daran hat
sich leider nicht viel geändert zu haben
denn auch der zeit geht es wieder um ein
genozid ahles russland allerdings nur
noch um russland
um einen terror start der sowohl
militärisch als auch wirtschaftlich von
tag zu tag schwächer wird sicher derzeit
scheint moskau die sanktionen des
westens noch zu verkraften was aber wenn
europa ist tatsächlich schafft sich vom
russischen gas und öl unabhängig zu
machen momentan reduzierte russland
selbst die gas lieferung nach europa in
erheblichem ausmaß angeblich weil ihnen
überall ersatzteile von siemens zählen
auf der anderen seite behauptet der
kreml jedoch die sanktionen würden der
russischen wirtschaft doch überhaupt
nichts ausmachen sie sogar noch stärker
und unabhängiger machen wie kann es dann
aber sein dass die mächtige russische
industrie nicht in der lage ist ein paar
ersatzteile für ihre eigenen vitale gas
infrastruktur her bestellen zu
beschossen oder wenigstens auf lager zu
halten so dass ein reibungsloser betrieb
über wenigstens ein paar monate möglich
wäre wie lange können russischen
fabriken und rohstofffirmen überhaupt
noch produzieren wenn ihnen keine
bauteile mehr aus dem westen geliefert
werden fakt ist auf lange sicht sieht es
für die russische wirtschaft verdammt
düster aus schaut euch dazu einfach mal
das neueste spitzenprodukt an dass die
russische automobilbranche zu bieten hat
den lada granta diese ikone russischen
fortschritt wird im juli auf den lokalen
markt geworfen und verfügt wieder über
eine servolenkung doch über abs
vorsprung durch technik sieht anders aus
nicht wahr diese mangelwirtschaft die
sich durch alle branchen und wird immer
schlimmer von der technik abhängig
landwirtschaft über die rüstung bis eben
auch zur rohstoffförderung ohne
westliche technik und know how geht
entweder gar nichts oder wenn etwas geht
geht viel weniger und die produktivität
und qualität stürzten ins bodenlose
die ohnehin schon sehr fehleranfälligen
waffensysteme der russischen armee
werden noch weiter gegenüber der nato
pornos zurückfallen moderne
kriegsführung des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts kann sie bald vollständig
vergessen zumal sie bereits jetzt im
donbass nicht viel mehr zustande bringt
als plumpe artillerieattacken auf niveau
des ersten weltkriegs wohlgemerkt mit
artillerie systemen die den der nato in
puncto reichweite treffgenauigkeit und
blindgänger quote um jahrzehnte
hinterher hinken russische aktuelle
regen panzerhaubitzen 2000 ist in etwa
so als würde manfred von richthofen in
seinem 3 becker gegen top gun kampfjets
antreten und da die ukraine nun immer
mehr auf nato niveau ausgerüstet wird
schmelzen die chancen russlands im krieg
gegen sie mit jeder weiteren lieferung
daher ist vor allem eines klar auch wenn
es zeiten gab zudem die nato und der
warschauer pakt waffengleichheit
erreicht hatten hat es russland nie
geschafft die niederlage der sowjetunion
im wettrüsten 1980 er jahre auch noch
annähernd aufzuholen nun hat sie rein
gar keine chance dazu darüber hinaus hat
das atlantische bündnis wurde weit mehr
mitglieder als noch während des ersten
kalten kriegs natürlich heißt das nicht
dass die nato keine probleme hätte
dennoch stellt heute niemand mehr weder
ihre notwendigkeit noch ihre strategisch
vorteilhafte lage in frage zumal ihre
probleme gegenüber den von russland und
china mittlerweile wie kinkerlitzchen
wirken eher luxus probleme denn vitale
showstopper und für die usa als genial
macht ist die nato somit quasi ein
riesiger hebel ein so großer hebel wie
nie zuvor denn es gibt nicht nur um den
europäischen schauplatz
für uns europäer geht manchmal
unterdessen asiatisch pazifischen raums
die usa aus politischer wirtschaftlicher
und blickt irische sicht eine top
priorität genießt schließlich handelt es
sich um den bevölkerungsreichsten und
ökonomisch am schnellsten wachsenden
wirtschaftsraum der welt derzeit haben
die usa allerdings nur wenige verbündete
nach nato vorbild in dieser region ich
meine damit verbündete die willens und
in der lage sind belastbare militärische
zusagen zu machen dies hat einen
einfachen grund china sitzt dem
interessantesten anwärtern für eine
solche strategische partnerschaft stets
im nacken vor allem mit seiner
wirtschaftsmacht allerdings dürfen wir
bei alldem nicht vergessen dass china
vor shipping ein durchaus welt offenes
und freundliches land war und einige der
schwierigkeiten aber auch gewisse
chancen der usa bei der partnersuche zu
verstehen ist ein kleiner exkurs in die
geschichte der region hilfreich
hierbei wenn wir uns beispielhaft gibt
nimmt zu es geht um einen krieg in
vietnam die im westen kaum jemand
wahrgenommen hat denn wenn wir vom wird
man krieg sprechen meint wird im
konflikt zwischen nord und süd wird mit
den usa an der seite sieht wird man so
und china und der sowjetunion auf der
seite nordvietnams zusammen mit seinem
vorläufer kriegen erstreckt er sich über
ganze 20 jahre von 1955 bis 1975 dessen
ende das durchaus ähnlichkeiten mit dem
debakel in afghanistan hatte kennen wir
alle us-hubschrauber evakuieren menschen
von den dächern sei gott
1979 brachte dann jedoch ein weiterer
krieg in vietnam aus dieses mal ging es
aber nicht mehr um einen konflikt
zwischen kommunismus und kapitalismus
sondern wenn ich die nächste
chinesischen krieg zwischen zwei
kommunistischen mächten welcher jedoch
zusätzlich noch in den sogenannten
dritten indochinakrieg eingebettet war
ihr habt davon noch nie was gehört keine
sorge ihr seid nicht die einzigen für
die westliche geo strategie waren
regionale konflikte dieser art bislang
auch von wenig interesse in letzter zeit
hat sich diese situation allerdings
vollkommen geändert denn der chinesische
riese als wirtschaftliche und
militärische supermacht rückt seine
vielen territorialen konflikte der
vergangenheit wieder auf das politischen
schachbrett und genau das macht in der
region sehr viele nervös
an dieser stelle können wir nicht auf
alle länder einzeln angehen aber es gibt
eine reihe von gewaltvideos indem wir
auf die spezifischen aspekte vieler
staaten in diesem teil der welt eingehen
bzw noch eingehen werden wie eben zum
beispiel auch das spannungsverhältnis
zwischen china und vietnam zu denen er
ein paar videos in vorbereitung haben
nun aber zum kern unserer aussage von
taiwan bis japan oder südkorea oder
sogar indonesien immerhin ein land mit
87% muslimischer bevölkerung wendet er
seit einem wettrüsten statt mit dem ziel
die ambitionen chinas einzudämmen und
washington ist überall zur stelle um
dabei neuen potentiellen strategischen
partnern zur seite zu stehen in tunesien
begrüßt neue ära der beziehungen zu den
usa und hält die größten gemeinsamen
militärübungen ab im falle vietnams kann
allerdings noch nicht unbedingt von
einem bündnis sprechen
seit den 1960 er jahren ist vietnam
traditionell ein verbündeter russlands
und das bedeutet dass es bis vor kurzem
noch gemeinsame militärübungen mit
russland ab hielt allerdings in sich
hanna und washington mittlerweile so
nahe gekommen wie nie zuvor seit 2016
können us-kriegsschiffe sogar in
vietnamesischen hafen festmachen und
wenn das kein eindeutiges zeichen ist
was sich auch nicht schließlich wollen
sich die ambitionierten und
aufstrebenden lesen versinkenden
russland nicht mit in den abgrund ziehen
lassen knallt sie wohl in der
weltgeschichte auf der siegerseite
stehen und diese ist heute normal mehr
denn je die der usa durch ironische
wendung wie es doch ist knapp 50 jahre
nachdem sie dieses selbst besiegt haben
und was ist mit den anderen
asiatisch-pazifischen ländern nun im
grunde treffen wir jedes mal auf eine
sehr ähnliche geschichte pentagon
verdoppelt unter beiden die zahl der
us-truppen in taiwan falls ihr fleißig
visual politiker seid habt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon mal was von der
quad gehört über die wehr ein eigenes
video gedreht haben dass ich euch
verlinkt werden für quad zählen neben
den vereinigten staaten indien japan und
australien
darüber hinaus gibt es weitere
zusammenschlüsse den ibf das indo
pacific economic work party oder den
medien die association of south asian
nations
hierbei handelt es die visa zion die
washington derzeit für sich gewinnen
möchte und das durchaus mit erfolg so
sind zb die neuen regierung in südkorea
und japan pro amerikanischer denn je das
ziel der beiden regierung ist dabei
offensichtlich sie möchte alle
asiatischen länder die sich derzeit von
china bedroht fühlen unter ihrer führung
militärisch vereinen wie gesagt klappt
das im moment auch ganz gut
[Musik]
aber kann man deshalb schon von einer
neuen asiatischen abzusprechen nun noch
nicht denn verhandlungen über eine
vergleichbare organisation werden sich
noch über jahre hinziehen dennoch führt
das alles zu folgendem fakt innerhalb
der letzten zehn jahre waren die usa
militärisch nie stärker in asien
engagiert und auch dominant als dies
heutzutage der fall ist gut viele von
euch werden jetzt sicher denken aber
china wirst du doch auch in einem
bislang ungeahnten ausmaß auf und damit
habt ihr recht das gleiche gilt
allerdings auch für seinen nachbarn
welche er den usa nahe stehen
zusammengefasst kann man also sagen dass
die allianzen der usa sowohl im
pazifischen als auch im atlantischen
raum nun so stark sind in nie zuvor
tendenz weiter steigend währenddessen
wäre ihre widersacher china und russland
zunehmend isoliert beziehungsweise im
falle russlands gaben marginalisiert und
zwar nicht nur durch die usa sie selbst
schrecken durch ihr auftreten ihren
nachbarn ja geradezu ab das jüngste
beispiel ist kasachstan dessen
herrschaft wohl keinen bock mehr zu
haben scheint ein einflussbereich eines
größenwahnsinnigen versorgers wie putin
zu versauern klar china wie russland
schaffen es zwar einige eher
schwächelnde länder auf ihre seite zu
ziehen oder für sich abhängig zu machen
aber eigentlich niemanden der ihnen im
fall der fälle wirklich helfen könnte
oder würde es handelt sich durch die
bank weg um ratten und wir alle wissen
was diese tun wenn das schiff auch ein
anzeichen des sinkens aufweist aufgrund
all dieser entwicklungen müssen wir
daher immer mehr statt von einer
multipolaren welt er von einer monopol
arenberg sprechen eine entwicklung die
nun klarer denn je geworden ist und sich
in zukunft noch weiter verstärken wird
die preisfrage lautet daher glaubt ihr
dass die usa tatsächlich irgendwann
einmal die absolute weltherrschaft
erlangen werden wie könnte der weg dahin
aussehen könnte china nach ski wieder zu
einer nicht konfrontativen macht wehren
welches schicksal erwartet dann russland
wenn es sich nicht von putins regime
befreien kann und was haltet ihr von der
tatsache dass die vereinigten staaten
heute und in zukunft mehr denn je die
rolle der weltpolizei einnehmen die
immer sind eure diskussionsbeiträge zu
diesem thema im kommentarbereich schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat und vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt weil es ja
gibt uns mit teils mit freunden und gebt
uns bitte ein abo mit glöckchen damit er
keines unserer glücklos mit verpasst
natürlich wollen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mit uns hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den paypal
mit ihrer beschreibung unter den video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]